These are my disclosures.
So as Usai just said, you know, the Bcl-2 inhibitors are clearly an active class of
drugs in mantle cell lymphoma, but I would argue that their strongest role is in combination
with other active regimens.
And I do think they make great combination partners for several reasons: they have a
unique mechanism of action, they have an overall favorable safety profile, and there's preclinical
evidence of synergy with the BTKI, which are one of the most active class of drugs in mantle
cell lymphoma.
There's also already compelling clinical data with Venetoclax combinations in mantle
cell lymphoma, particularly with the BTK inhibitors, with or without anti-CD20 monoclonal antibodies,
and I've listed a few examples of key studies here, including Sepetico, Oasis-1 and 2, Traverse
and Ambovin.
And as also discussed just now, snorotoclax is a next-generation Bcl-2 inhibitor.
With greater preclinical selectivity and potency compared with venetoclax.
So in terms of clinical trials of snorotoclax-based combinations in mantle cell lymphoma, we only
have this one trial, which is a phase one trial of snorotoclax and zanubrutinib.
Zanubrutinib was given as the standard dose, and then there were escalated doses of snorotoclax.
There was an 8-12 week lead-in with zanubrutinib monotherapy before snorotoclax.
And in this case, there was an 8-12 week lead-in with zanubrutinib monotherapy before snorotoclax.
And only a very small percentage of patients had prior covalent BTKI.
In terms of safety, it's what you'd expect from the combination of a BCL2 inhibitor and a BTKI.
GI toxicity, especially diarrhea, which was mostly grade 1 and 2.
Nausea, neutropenia, thrombocytopenia, but low risk of neutropenic fever, and no laboratory or clinical TLS.
In terms of safety, the overall response rate in the patient was very low.
The overall response rate in the overall cohort was 79%, including CR, at 66%.
Notably, 7 patients, or 15% of patients, progressed prior to receiving snorotoclax during the 8-12 week lead-in with zanubrutinib monotherapy.
And then of the four evaluable patients with prior BTKI, one achieved PR and one achieved CR.
And the median follow-up duration for this study is very short, it's less than a year and a half.
But the 24-month duration of response rate for all patients was 85%.
So based on this, there's the ongoing phase 3 celestial trial in mantle cell lymphoma,
which is a phase 3 randomized double-blinded study in patients with 1 to 5 prior lines of treatment.
No prior BCL2 inhibitors are allowed, and no prior covalent or non-covalent BTKI are allowed,
unless the BTKI was stopped due to intolerance.
Patients are randomized 1 to 1 to receive zanubrutinib alone or with snorotoclax.
Zanubrutinib is given as the standard dose until progression.
And then snorotoclax is started in cycle 2, so we lead in with zanubmonotherapy for only 4 weeks.
And then snorotoclax is continued for 2 years.
And the primary endpoint is PFS.
This trial is ongoing.
And then another trial, this is led by the cooperative group and by Dr. Reem Karmali.
This is actually still in development, it hasn't opened yet.
But it's for patients with previously untreated mantle cell lymphoma who are 70 years or younger.
All patients start with zanubrutinib for 1 cycle.
And in the main cohort, patients are randomized to a triangle-like approach with BR and zanubrutinib for 6 cycles,
and then receive maintenance rituksin and zanubrutinib for 2 years.
And the other arm receives chemotherapy-free triplet regimen with zanubrutinib, snorotoclax, and obin for 12 cycles.
So kind of bovine-like, but with snorotoclax.
And then go on to receive obin and zanubrutinib for a year and a half.
This ends up being that the two treatment arms have similar treatment duration.
And then there's a small cohort of patients with TP53 aberrant mantle cell lymphoma
who will receive the triplet, same triplet, zanubrutinib, obin, and snorotoclax for 12 cycles.
And then are randomized to maintenance obin for a year and a half in combination with zanubrutinib, or Glowfit with zanubrutinib.
And zanubrutinib here is until progression for both arms in the TP53 cohort.
Another trial is, this is actually an IST from Dana-Farber, led by Dr. Christine Ryan,
also for patients with previously untreated mantle cell lymphoma who are eligible for high-dose citerabine,
where patients receive 3 cycles of zanubrutinib and BR,
and then 3 cycles of rituksin and high-dose citerabine without zanubrutinib,
and then are randomized to zanubrutinib.
They are randomized to zanubrutinib alone or with snorotoclax for 2 years.
And the primary endpoint is the rate of CR with triplet blood MRD negativity after 1 year of maintenance treatment.
And then we heard about some of the basket trials that will include BTK degraders with snorotoclax,
but these are not specific for mantle cell lymphoma yet,
but I think this is a combination that also makes sense in mantle cell lymphoma.
And that's it. Thank you.
next we'll have